- All right, bladesmiths.
On your anvils is a cloth.
Go ahead and lift that up.
That is a pristine
piece of 5160 steel.
And I'm sure you're
thinking, man, I
can make a hell of a
signature blade out of that.
However, that's not
what we're doing today.
Instead, you'll be
forging friction folders.
Really?
Why a folder?
It's a moving knife.
I mean, the more moving
parts in something, the more
parts that can go wrong.
The blade parameters
are as follows.
The length of the blade
not including the tang
must be between 8 and
10 inches in length.
You will have three hours
to forge your blades.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
Your 10 minute design
window starts now.
JACOB: 90% of the time, I
don't even draw a knife.
I'll just get a
dream or something
and I'll just make it.
In this competition, I need
to draw this thing out to make
sure I don't make any mistakes.
I decided my design's
gonna be a clip point.
I don't know exactly
what abuse they're
going to put on that blade.
And they don't usually snap.
HOST: Bladesmiths, your
design period is over.
Your three hour foraging
time starts now.
MAN: These guys have got
to be focused on the specs.
Otherwise, those friction
folders aren't going to hold.
BLADESMITH 1: You got
to plan ahead of time
what you're going to do.
And I can't do it on the fly.
The area of the ricasso is
so much more important now--
placement of your
pin for the pivot
and then your tail for that tank
that's going to lock everything
together when you hold it.
JACOB: After I get my
tang stretched way out,
I'm trying to think, what's
going to set me apart from all
these other guys in here?
JUDGE 1: Jacob's put
a decorative twist.
JUDGE 2: How good
of a strategy is it
to put that decorative twist?
It's not bad if he
still grinds it flat.
Yeah.
JUDGE 2: Uh-huh.
So it still fits in
the slot in his handle.
JUDGE 1: Long as it doesn't
create a nice spot to chew
the heck out of your palm.
- Yeah.
JACOB: I'm drying
this knife out.
And I'm like, wait a second.
This thing long enough?
HOST: If I were him, I'd try
and draw another inch or so out
of that blade for a ricasso.
JACOB: Now I realize
this blade is like right
on the dot of eight inches.
I can't work with that because
I don't have any freedom
to do anything with it, really.
Like, I had to draw it
out a little bit more.
Has to be within the parameters.
And if it's not, I'm gone.
Hoo!
HOST: Bladesmiths!
You have just 60
minutes remaining.
JACOB: Yeah, that's good.
Jacob didn't draw that
blade out some more.
JUDGE 3: Without a ricasso.
JUDGE 1: There's a little
bit of a ricasso there.
JACOB: I'm trying to
figure out exactly where
I need to drill my hole at.
I look next to me
at Fuad's blade.
And his blade is like, wow.
Mine's looking pretty good.
But I can't make any mistakes.
[blade sound] nice and slow just
to make sure I get it right.
HOST: 10, 9, 8, 7,
6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, shut
down your machines.
This round is over.
JACOB: I'm feeling pretty
good about my blade.
I got it finished.
I looked over all the guys.
And now I'm second
guessing myself
because mine's the
shortest blade.
But it's within the parameters.
They shouldn't have
any complaints.
HOST: Bladesmiths, it's
time for the judges
to take a closer
look at your work.
Greg, you're up first.
I was a little bit
worried in the heat treat.
This thing was glowing.
And you even picked up
some of that dragon scaling
where the skin kind of
burnt on this blade.
Hopefully you've
nailed that heat
treat and you didn't quench
it too hot, making it brittle.
HOST: All right, Kyle.
JUDGE 1: The biggest
problem I see
is when you look down
the edge, there's
kind of a corkscrew to it.
And that's-- that's a
difficult warp to fix.
HOST: All right, Jacob.
JUDGE 4: Extra points for
putting the twist because it's
going to make it look good.
But remember, the
tang is the area where
you're going to hold onto it.
So be careful in how this
will feel in the hand
if you move forward.
I like the fact that you've
got it very, very straight.
But you're only going to have
a quarter inch of material
in front of that pin, making
an incredibly weak spot.
HOST: Well, bladesmiths.
The judges have made
their final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave the forge.
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Kyle.
Kyle, I loved the
profile of that blade,
having that sweep coming up.
But if you look down the
length of that blade right now,
you'll see that blade goes
down three different directions
looking on the spine side.
If you turn it over
and look at the edge,
you've got a severe twist
going off to one side.
It's going to be almost
impossible to fix that twist.
So that's why we're
letting you go.
Thank you.